ragazzi tornati a una puntata cucina
buttata questa è l'ultima puntata
diciamo di quella che è la nostra
programmazione tipica prima del blog ma
dal primo dicembre al 25 dicembre
infatti faremo un video al giorno senza
mai fermarci quest'anno però ci sono
delle sorprese assurde e folli perché
abbiamo deciso di alzare l'asticella
stiamo per entrare dopo controlli di
sicurezza tamponi e compagnia bella
all'interno di una casa nella quale
vedremo fino alla vigilia di natale
rischiamo di impazzire rischiava di
farci amare ma ci saranno un botto di
novità vi giuro un bottom bottoli novità
in questa puntata di cucina buttata
abbiamo deciso di farci togliere la
cittadinanza italiana perché su
instagram mi è arrivato un messaggio la
partita del sanda che mi suggeriva di
sperimentare una nuova leccornia
americana la pizza scomposta in
barattolo so che ogni volta che dico
pizza scopo stai in barattolo
probabilmente un napoletano ha un
attacco di diarrea a ombrello io vi
chiedo scusa se siete deboli di cuore
non andate avanti con questo video però
magari se volete supportarci metteteci
un laico anche senza creare la ricetta e
soprattutto iscrivetevi a questo canale
attiva della campana delle notifiche
anche se vi faccio vedere io di a questo
punto di partire subito con ingredienti
per la pizza scomposta in barattolo
avrete bisogno di un barattolo pasta
della pizza già pronta tomatoes morello
che sa di suola di scarpa un basilisco
sale e oggi continua a fare questo ogni
due secondi
paparazzi richiameranno vladimir
l'impalatore comunque è presente in nero
di whatsapp non è oggi è uno dei
personaggi più famosi del mondo il nervo
non è mai visto al rimessaggio corsa
ecco io a fare il bianco preferisco
chiamarlo mio marito vabbè comunque che
voi io vado un po alla si odiano verso
prende il sale e il cielo butto dentro
arrivino la rim inabile io sinceramente
non so bene cosa stiamo facendo perché
lo stiamo facendo secondo me potrebbe
far veramente creare se possono ripetere
una sorpresa una cosa che dovreste fare
tutti quanti
si è allora in tal caso quello dovesse
accadere al camionista grande ma questa
appartiene alla famiglia delle varie
pizze all'ananas e quelle ricette della
orribile possiamo andare avanti nei test
e buttiamo no tesoro perché così non si
attacca al fondo e barattolo e tutta
scomposta e tutto quanto stracciato ti
faccio vedere ma ti faccio prendere un
colpo metterò si sta per farlo
all'americana mozzarella prima ancora di
mettere capitolo una pizza che si sta
sentendo male metà il modo di fare
marketing che mi odia scriva ti adoro
commentate con sei bravissimo si pensa a
ritirarmi
prendo questa strappo come viene ragazzo
avere con doppio mozzarella certo ora ne
abbiamo subito signore della cosa bella
è che non verrà manco una schifezza
fermi ci stiamo così illuminando il
gusto è una pizza in un barattolo
pomodoro mozzarella pasta della pista
per rimettere e basilico e cominciò a
mettere della carta che faccia una
velocità doppia mozzarella per il signor
quando solo di mia sorella ora è pronta
ma questa crisi carbonizzato ricordo io
resto già posti fa questa compagnia
crudo io trovo abominevole questa cosa
sta facendo
delizioso io soprattutto mozzarella
adesso ho capito prendo e ributto quali
raccomando raccoglie olina di basilico
sul finale l'ultimo vasetto a metà
concetto d'olio a crudo rec non si mette
a nudo e crudo di te le sirene della
polizia ci stanno venendo a prendere
anche lamenti così a caso la pasta della
pizza come una mettereste il 50 per
cento delle ricette che cuciniamo
mediamente è peggio di questa qual è la
tua pizza preferita margherita
chiaramente fortunato se fortunato
quadrato ammessa preferita la vita con
molta lella di bufala aspetta un'altra
gara ce la metto sulla mozione bufala
eccola qui giovedì col talent era la mia
pizza preferita da margherita per fame
piccante è nadia vola ultimamente è lei
che era la mia preferita da bambino lo
so io la chiamo da bambino c'è sempre
qualche salame nella tua testa
fateci sapere qual era la vostra pizza
preferita da bambini e quale adesso e
imbarazzo la mia preferita è imparato
che il profumo del basilico marco otto
anni mariko enrico mettiamo tutto questo
vediamo nella tua per quanto dobbiamo
tenerlo secondo voi può più gianmarco e
militante che siamo questi si è già
punta non farti domande vara e silenzio
non fatemi domande io devo dire una cosa
lo trovo deliziosa ok
in bocca al lupo ragazzi prende fuoco da
fuoco anche all'altro barattolo però la
mia amica
alla faccia andare intanto in dieci
minuti che se tra cinque minuti
sì ma non è in un barattolo immersa
nella cosa che quindi non la fa cucinare
quella dovrà di scaldarsi tanto sentite
facciamo 8 minuti e più fidati di me in
tanto che vediamo poi che succede
torniamo tra poco allora sono passati
otto minuti non so voi ma non sentite un
buon odore
domenico ciao ciao
facciamo dieci minuti ciao ci vediamo
oppure un motore si stanno pattinando
possiamo definirlo ragazzi sono confuso
perché sono intrigato l'aspetto per me
non è brutto cioè se mi dice che una
pizza in barattolo scomposta ti dico 3
ma così è pure carino so io gli darei un
7 l'autore non è che gli si può dare
poco e tutto quello che ti aspetteresti
di sentire sette e mezzo sapore
leggermente cruda voglio premiare
l'impegno do sette meno se avessi parla
di nuovo prenderei 2 passera rezza
cuocere su una padella la farei in tanti
pezzettini e la butterà e qui già un po
cotta complessivo 7 più sarei disposto a
pagare un 6 euro
la cosa dice
partiamo questo sport allora io non sono
un padre le pizze in barattolo è la
prima volta che ne mangiò una e
mangiavano ok sto per mangiarla pertanto
il soggetto che la maggio ancora non è
il momento giusto
la osservo un altro po prima di
assaggiarla come la loro d'ore non è
male sa di pizza in barattolo 7 e allora
mangiamo la buona dopo l'altro boccone
sette e mezzo per neve zucchine o il
baratto l'assaggio tutti gli aspetti si
presenta
[Musica]
adesso comunque ragazzi siamo ragazzi al
fine di questo video ve lo ripeto noi
dal primo dicembre inizieremo il blog
massimi le 20 speriamo che per questi 25
giorni che ci separeranno al natale e
voi possiate seguirci quotidianamente su
youtube su instagram e su tante altre
piattaforme nuove mi raccomando rimanete
collegati perché ci sarà del delirio è
come sempre iscrivetevi al questo canale
fatelo davvero attiva della campagna
delle notifiche ma fatelo davvero
mettete un bel light un bel pollice in
su ma fatelo davvero noi ci vediamo non
ci credo che lo sto per dire che ci
stiamo per fare questa cosa per un terzo
anno di fila il primo dicembre con la
prima puntata del blog mas